بطل اللحظات الحرجه حارس عرين الارجنتين
الرجل الذي يحب ميسي ومستعد للموت من اجله
ليس بالقول فقط بل بالفعل ايضا كيف لا وهو
الذي انقذ مرمى منتخب التانجو من عده كره
خطيره خلال بطوله كاس العالم وقادهم بتصدي
لركله ترجيحيه الى التتويج بلقب بالاغلاق
ايميليان ومارتيريس كما يراقبه عشاق
الارجنتين كان احد ابطال المنتخب
الارجنتيني في السنوات الاخيره ساهم بعده
القاب بدايه من كوبا امريكا
بكل الجهود التي حققها في بطوله كاس
العالم الاخيره شخصيته مليان والجريئه
والمتحفزه جعلته محطه انظار العالم لكن
بعد تصرفاته الطائشه خصوصا في تتويج
الارجنتين الاخير جعلت منه حديث الصحف
والانتقادات حول شخصيته المستفز من دموع
الفقر الى دموع الفرح لحظاتهم تلخص
مسيرتها طويله لحارس منتخب الارجنتين
المتوج بكاس العالم مليانو مارتينيز الذي
عاش صبرا مرا لاكثر من 10 سنوات قبل ان
يفتح القدر له ابواب المسجد واسعه من
مارديل بلاتا احد مدن العاصمه بين سايرس
حمل مارتينيز احلامه الكبيره وخوفه
الطبيعي تاركا عائلته الفقيره لبكاء
الفراق وقاطعا المحيط الاطلسي ليصل الى
انجلترا ويوقع عقده هناك مع فريق ارسنال
عام 2010 حيث كانت المهمه الصعبه في اثبات
الذات بعمر صغير لم يتجاوز حينها في
بريطانيا كانت المهمه صعبه منافسه شرسه مع
كبار حراس الفريق الاندري منعت الحارس
الارجنتيني الصغير من صنع اسم له ليكون
خيار اعارته بالنسبه لاداره النادي هو
الابرز ولينتقل خلال ثمان سنوات بين عده
انديه مغموره كان افضلها دون ان يضمن
مكانا في التشكيل الاساسي لاي منها العمر
يمضي والاحلام تتبخر لكن لحظه هناك فرصه
تلوح بوفقه حياه مارتيناز الارسنال يفقد
حريسه لينو للاصابه وليس هناك مفر من
مشاركه ايميليانو الذي كان على قدر المهمه
واستطاع حمايه عرين ارسنال ليس ذلك فحسب
بلدهم للتتويج بكاس الاتحاد الانجليزي عام
الامر الذي لم يتحقق اذا ما بقي على مقاعد
البدلاء يختار الانتقال الى الصلب الى كل
الحارس الاساسي للفريق الجديد الامر الذي
حمله الى حراسه مرمى الارجنتين والاساسيه
في الارجنتين كانت لحظات الفرح الحقيقيه
ثلاث بطولات في اقل من عامين بدايه من كاس
كوبا امريكا ومن بعدها بطوله فينال سيما
ثم كاس العالم اللقب الاغني مسيره جعلت من
امليانه بطلا حقيقيا في بلاده
وبطوله شعبها الكثير من الانتقادات في
الايام الاخيره بسبب سوء سلوكه بدايه من
الاشاره التي فعلها اثناء التتويج
الارجنتين بكاس العالم ومن بعدها رفعه
لدنيا تشبه في مسيره المنتخب في الارجنتين
يكون الاكثر اثاره الجدل بين اعضاء
التانجو